[Music]
this is for the lgbtqai
black latina asian
the many multi beautiful
colors of the rainbow around the
freaking world this is not just for me
this is for y'all yes
that is mj rodriguez reacting live on
instagram last night after making
history for becoming the first trans
woman to ever win a golden globe
there are going to be so many young
individuals young talented thriving
individuals that are going to be able to
trail in and storm in through the door
this is for y'all the only way to win a
trophy is if you work really hard
i got some tricks up my sleeve
i can teach you if you want mj won the
award for best actress in a television
series drama for her role as blanca on
pose which ran for three seasons mj's
win also is the very first golden globe
win for pose so what you gotta do work
harder
and dream big until you
[Music]
mj also made history last year when she
became the first trans woman to receive
an emmy nomination in a lead acting
category and when we caught up with her
she spoke about the power of her
nomination it's no longer a space where
discrimination because of who we are
that's no longer the case we're showing
up and we're doing the work
mj also posted this to her instagram
following her win saying they will see
that a young black latina girl from
newark new jersey who had a dream to
change the minds of others would with
love
love wins to my young lgbtqai babies we
are here the door is now open now reach
the stars
[Music]